única de una noche de hace seis años que
todavía tiene más interrogantes que
certezas el 26 de septiembre en igual al
sur de méxico en el estado de guerrero
43 estudiantes de una escuela de
maestros de ayotzinapa desaparecieron
después de haberse apropiado de varios
autobuses para dirigirse a una protesta
en ciudad de méxico los días siguientes
hoy sólo se han identificado a tres de
las víctimas para intentar aclarar este
caso el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador anunció por primera vez órdenes
de captura contra los militares como
presuntos autores intelectuales y
materiales hay condiciones
inmejorables
para saber sobre el paradero de los
muchachos el papel de las autoridades es
fundamental en esta desaparición según
la investigación que se hizo durante el
gobierno de enrique peña nieto- fueron
unos policías corruptos los que
entregaron a los estudiantes a miembros
de un cartel quienes los habrían
asesinado e incinerado pesquisas
posteriores de la cdh y del grupo
interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes rechazaron la versión
conocida como la verdad histórica
las familias siguen exigiendo respuestas
y justicia pero si pedirle que apriete
un poquito más
nosotros queríamos llegar hoy 26 pues
con algo más no que entienda nos ya seis
años
y pues no tenemos nada en las órdenes de
captura también se influyen a policías
municipales y federales cobrador que
ofreció disculpas en nombre del país ha
prometido aclarar un crimen que
evidenció la fragilidad del estado de
derecho en méxico